a new push on immigration President
Trump is reaching across the aisle to
strike a deal with Democrats on
so-called dreamers in return the
president wants funding to pay for the
border wall some top priorities in his
70 point plan include building the wall
hiring 10,000 additional ice agents and
600 prosecutors mandatory e-verify
system which confirms an immigrants work
eligibility and a new points-based
system for green cards but don't expect
a deal from the Democrats Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer and House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi are already
saying no thanks
quote we told the president at our
meeting that we were open to reasonable
border security measures alongside the
DREAM Act but this list goes so far
beyond what is reasonable this proposal
fails to represent any attempt to
compromise meanwhile the president's
counselor has this message for critics
on the left they should actually be
calling their friends Chuck and Nancy to
say you know are you going to give up
this deal because you don't want to get
why don't you want a border wall
constructed why don't you want more
immigration judges and agents and why
isn't a reasonable policy to limit chain
migration and also to stop these visa
overstays and to make sure people that
are flouting the law once they're here
breaking the law also here go back okay
so I'm Jesse what do you make of this
plan the Democrats obviously pushing
back
but Trump aka the wall pushing forward
that's right well crying Chuck needs to
put down the New York Times and start
reading the art of the deal because this
is classic Trump you start with a big
ask and then you dial it back and end up
getting 75% of what you want I'm sick of
hearing this is a non-starter can we ban
that phrase yes according to Democrats
anything the Republicans propose is a
non-starter the Democrats idea of
compromise is a hundred percent of what
they want I understand why though
because the Republicans in Congress have
caved and buckled for the last eight
years so it's two prong strategy here
one you insert the wall and at the last
minute you dial it back and then you
look like you're flexible and a big
leader or you take the wall to the limit
and make the
Democrats look like rigid radicals but
here he still has a trump card he can
extend daca if he doesn't like the terms
for an extra six months so he controls
the whole debate the issue though is the
wall isn't as popular as protecting
dreamers but I don't think Trump cares
about polling and I think his base is
gonna stay with them no matter what Lee
cares about that base exactly he does
care but he also cares about the big
beautiful wall mm-hmm
big and beautiful gray I'm a dreamer I
dream about the wall but you know these
are their green cards they're not gift
cards I think somewhere along the line
we look we lost our way what's wrong
with a little bit of processing a little
bit of rules I don't think it's that big
of a deal but 70 points that's a lot of
points did you imagine being a thousand
points of being in that meeting you know
point twenty to forty seven more points
it's refreshing to hear you talk about
rules and process so it's such a
respectful way this is an interesting no
this is an interesting point because the
argument that the Democrats have about
immigration is exactly the opposite of
their argument for gun control
they don't want laws that go with
immigration they go what why do we need
more laws why do we need more laws we
need sanctuary because you know it
they're good but that's exactly opposite
the gun control law argument which is we
need more laws we need more friction we
need to slow things down but they can't
do it with immigration I find that very
interesting by the way that can work
both ways you could say that somebody
that argues against gun control laws why
do they want laws for immigration
Governor Jerry Brown doing that with
California essentially making it a
sanctuary state they want to put you
know and make their own laws and play by
their own rules but yet they don't like
these over here hello Juan Wow I see it
so differently because I realized that
there was a deal in place a deal between
the President and Chuck and Nancy right
and then the president has in a group of
Republican senators who say hey we think
you are pushing us out mr. president we
don't like this why don't we look
at some principles that we can employ
with regard to immigration and so then
having struck a deal with Chuck and
Nancy guess what huh calm Chansey
Chansey all right hashtag chancy he's he
then goes back to them and says here's
my principles well wait a second wait a
second then nobody does business this
way nobody does the deal we say it's all
on my terms or no terms or the highway
and that's what he did so then when you
when the Democrats say excuse us that's
not the deal we discussed because they
had agreed by the way Jesse to added
security on the border as part of their
deal and they had agreed that they want
either they want so many of these things
so what was a robber because Krupp has
just gone back and undone the deal and I
agree with what Gillian said ice I've
read Trump saying he cares about the
dreamers he did not want to do anything
to hurt the dreamers but we don't want
more dreamers and that's the point and
that's what the wall accomplishes to
wake up eventually but Jesse the
dreamers are a or a circumscribed group
they are not you can't add more sure you
can when you have more coming over
dreamers for a second there so religious
practices have to do it okay so hashtag
Chauncey whose theme song I guess is
gonna be ABBA
can see on me so Jillian I like what
you're saying you saying you know what
the president isn't trying to be mean
spirited or not honor those like
hardworking Americans who came here
perhaps you know you know fall directly
you know of their own so is there a way
to kind of make both sides happy a
little bit or will the Democrats just be
obstructionist because now you see
Chauncey saying now we have no bid for
this well I so I was surprised to see
what worries me in this proposal is
there is an element of using the
dreamers as a negotiating chip and
president Trump has taken great care in
many speeches many public remarks to
talk about the fact that emotionally and
psychologically he connects with the
idea that Amer
there should be a place to welcome these
people so I was disappointed by that but
my own political stuff aside for a
second I I think the proposal that was
submitted yesterday is really the
administration's answer to the criticism
that President Trump received in the
wake of the failed health care repeal
which is that he was not invested
personally he was not involved in the
process he was not in it down in the
nitty-gritty figuring this stuff out
trying to help Congress come up with the
specifics to populate this bill this is
something that's chock-a-block full of
specific no one can levy that criticism
again you know against him in this
instance I think that was really the
priority or was cobbling together a
complete plan so jellien the thing here
is though that when I just want to put
the point out there the president has
been willing to reach across to the
Democrats to try to find some common
ground he's doing that even right now
with Chuck Schumer as it relates to
health care and saying hey look I'm
willing to do a deal like can you guys
come and sit at the table nobody is you
can't say that he's not reached out that
regardless undercut the Democrats gonna
reach across and say okay yeah we're
actually gonna try and do something
that's in the best interest of the
country then you don't sit down to a
negotiation and put out your lowest
number yes it down and put out your
highest number and then negotiate out of
the deal down party it's it's what Jesse
said 70 70 point plan isn't what he's
expecting to get he if he gets 30 points
out of that that's a win and it also
exposes the fact that a Chauncey did not
read this because they didn't give
specifics he should've said well what do
you don't like about shove it through
and but you brought up the point about
how he's using daca is a chip that was
brilliant on his part because it wasn't
a chip he'd already give it into that
but he's still using it now he says you
know what you can have that but you knew
he was never gonna send those kids back
right though what are the families back
so he fabricated a chip out of something
that wasn't a chip also would you think
he would go if if Congress doesn't get
this done do you think that he'll go
back with an executive fix to the
problem do you think he'd go that far no
I don't think so no the base would freak
out after that and the politicians used
chips all the time they used the
military as a bargaining chip during the
debt ceiling right let's be honest
crowds don't want to secure the border
they like illegal immigration keep
criminal illegal in this country they
don't they're all for infrastructures
the walls gonna be made in America - why
don't you like that is that right I hope
so because it was going to be paid for
by the Mexican oh I didn't know we were
on Fantasy Island okay surrounded by
water yeah you know one of the arguments
that came from the dreamers remember
when they went and they got a Nancy
Pelosi space out in San Francisco pushed
her off remember that yes what were they
saying Jesse they were saying don't use
us as a football in your negotiations
with Donald Trump don't give in to added
security for this and added funding for
that we believe we have a case to make
the American people want us to stay why
are you guys making us a political
football and Nancy Pelosi remember she
ran off the stage you humiliated her you
you would enjoyed that much now guess
what here comes Donald Trump and he's in
trouble with the Republicans he says oh
wait a second I got some principles here
and he's changing the deal yeah what I'm
making on a deal that's not you know
listen he always said you wanted massive
border funding you would be through the
roof Jesse wouldn't because it wouldn't
happen to me will you compare an exit
question okay McLaughlin group if you
compare illegal immigration to the
Russian meddling why is one foreign
influence okay and the other one not not
supposed to be fair and it's not
supposed to be fair but it's a great
question non-starter
because it's a great question
why is it why is it illegal immigration
can have an impact on your elections and
on what you do but Russian meddling
can't great point what are you talking
about one is a domestic issue for us as
a lyrics are not domestic they're coming
there were Russians in here - oh is that
right yes okay read everything register
or not registering voting without
registering so voting illegally in this
country is that myth we could hardly you
know I'm talking about picketing talking
about demonstration like political
demonstrations keep up he's a Russian